how would I rape my own financial
expertise probably like a three I don't
understand how investing works I don't
know what songs are I feel overwhelmed
especially since like my parents have
supported me for so long I don't think I
have to put much thought into retirement
I'm kind of going by the Yolo and
spending my money when I get it how do I
not max help my credit card take your
credit cards and freeze them put them in
water
and freeze them in your freezer and then
start making payments to pay down your
card so if you need them you can get
access to them but because it's frozen
you won't be able to use it for any
impulse spending it's really helpful to
think about what you value as a person
and then actually take a look at where
you're spending money a lot of people
find that they're actually spending
money on things they don't value and if
you just make that adjustment you'll cut
down your spending I have tons of school
loans so I just want to know how will I
be able to pay these school loans off
and if I can't what are the consequences
look into different repayment plans and
loan forgiveness options there are a
number of repayment plans especially for
federal student loans right now the one
thing we never want to do is fall behind
on those loans and not even be making
minimum payments that are due in order
to protect our credit credit plays a
huge part in us buying a house financing
a car down the line and research all the
options that we have out there create a
plan and tackle them head on I worry
about whether or not social security
will be a thing when it's time for me to
retire and I wonder if it will or will
not be in one of my options if it's not
according to the most recent report put
out by the trustees of the social
security systems finances the funds are
expected to quote unquote run dry by the
Year 2034
that doesn't mean however that there
will no longer be any social security
benefits
it simply means those benefits will
likely be reduced what Millennials can
do however is really take charge of
their personal retirement savings by
utilizing accounts like an employer 401k
plan or using a traditional IRA or a
Roth IRA so that you're not entirely
dependent on those social security
benefits whatever they happen to be by
the time you retire when you're in your
20s you should be spending that time
really exploring and thinking about the
things that give you meaning once you
start growing up and living a life more
you won't be able to do that again and
that process that you can do up front is
gonna be way more important than any of
the smaller tactics other people might
tell you like start saving money to buy
a house get a job that's secure there is
no secure job anymore
that's gone and so I would say really
take that unattached time and spend it
figuring out like what makes you you and
what gives you meaning
you